so of course we know you most recently
for Game of Thrones very memorable scene
as well style boat areas now how did you
enjoy playing Rostov I loved playing
rosedale what was great was that I got
to add with dragons and I've never acted
with dragons before so that was quite
hard but it was a it was great I loved
it great location great actors yeah
fantastic location there tell us a
little bit more about it well we were
filming in Morocco in the desert in
Morocco and it was beautiful it was very
hot but it was great yeah I mean it was
where to go through the Atlas Mountains
which I've never been to in it so you
have to walk through the clouds to get
there which was amazing and you're
working with Emilia Clarke as well of
course Daenerys Targaryen what's he like
yeah she's lovely she's doubling we
actually went to the same drama school
so we had a lot since we had a lot to
talk about while doing a scene in
between fighting yeah she's lovely she's
very good actress yeah you mentioned the
Dragons of course as well such a
memorable scene there are many other
reasons what was it like working with it
it's obviously it's cgi isn't yeah I
mean I haven't really done much CGI so
it was quite new for me but on when
you're actually filming all it all they
are model dragons and so it's very hard
to kind of give that reaction but then
when you see it when you see the scene
then it makes sense in it and I thought
I felt I'd kind of got it quite right
I've I did anyway but it was a challenge
but I really enjoyed it i love to do
more dragon dragon work hopefully you
kind of excited them when you actually
watch the finished products on the TV at
the end of the day well normally I don't
like to watch what I do but when I I'm a
big fan of Game of Thrones so obviously
I had to watch it and it was a I was
really surprised actually I really
enjoyed it I really believed actually
which is good yeah
and the cost you as well tell me what it
was like being dressed up like that it
was great i mean it was very very hot
because it was layers and layers but the
costume is so detailed and so so
beautiful really very heavy but i loved
it i mean i think it's on show at the
moment an exhibition in LA I mean
they've done really well we all the
costumes such beautiful costumes yeah
it's so much attention to detail on the
shows it's incredible he's amazing I
mean what the production values are just
amazing I mean and they they're just so
I think they've won awards I mean for
for the costumes and for the makeup and
everything really and what kind of
qualities you think you need to stay
alive in Game of Thrones as we've seen
so many people fall by the wayside ever
worked well I think a game of thrones
the carrot what's so interesting about
the characters they're so multi-layered
and I think I think they need to be very
very manipulative and very conniving and
and and I think if you're if you're good
at that you seem to stay alive and I
think maybe that's one of the Collies
disease I'd love to develop with roz day
to stay alive who do you think will come
out on top at the end of days it's gonna
be the stark so I do think it's me the
Lannisters are the Targaryen what's the
hard one I'd like it to be the Starks
but I'm not so sure really I can't give
anything away it took all time in Series
three didn't know they did have a tough
all the time it was a it was a big
ending wasn't it so did he make the red
wedding what was your reaction shocked
Cora like everyone else I guess I people
put on people on Facebook we're going I
can't eat I'm so shocked I found out
about it when I was excited to have read
the books but I found about when I was
filming this my scenes for this and but
when I saw it I mean it is it is a huge
shock I know that's bit but as a bit
versal overdramatize but it was when I
remember what
and if you could have a big death scene
in the show how would you like to go out
I don't know i think i'd love to be so
thrown off a cliff or something and then
get eaten by dragons maybe definitely
some dragons i think of a dragons of
united's make sure you're dead by that
way when you throw your clippers and
then eaten by dragons i can fly me into
the ocean and throw me in fabulous and
they're keeping with the dramatic theme
of the show yeah exactly do you think
that we're likely to ever see ran style
again on the show would you like to be
on the Shogun I'd love to be on the show
again I was trying to get some
information out some of the people I've
met today because I haven't read the
books and I wondered whether in the
books you know the character comes back
but uh you never really know really
because even even in the books that they
sort of picked bits from different books
and add them in so you never really know
I hope so that's all I can say I mean
he's not dead so that's a good sign it's
not been flamed by dragons yet yes yes
but hopefully they'll be coming seas
season four or five six or something you
got lots of stuff coming up as well I
know you've been shooting 300 rise and
my which we're looking forward to seeing
how was that that was great that's
fantastic that was very different to
this but it was it was great and lots of
action yeah I've been deeded lots of
action stuff recently which I've never
really done before which has been nice
she's been nice yeah how do you pay
yourself when he doing that well I
thought I was going to go to the gym
five times a week but then I ended up
not and then yay then you end up on set
going I think I should have gone to the
gym because everyone's got these amazing
muscles everywhere and but hey I got
through what kind of role do you play in
three hundreds well it's just he's a row
is this a Greek he's a citizen of the
Greek court really
that's all it is it's not big role just
a small role by looking for to exist i
really enjoyed the film and being a
greek origin it was nice to kind of be
able to play that ancient ancestors and
also another exciting that you got
coming up the honorable woman i'm
playing the Palestinian ambassador in
that so I get to wear a suit and be very
professional which is unlike a lot of
the roles that I play Maggie is great to
work with she's um she's so easy to work
with and yeah no question it's a little
bit about what the kind of story line
people can expect from the show from the
number woman it's about the
israeli-palestinian situation so it's
very cool political drama but it's seen
for the eyes of a of a london-based
Jewish lady really who wants to make
peace in the Middle East and it's it's
political but what's good about it it
has it has a very strong sort of human
theme should we say it does it's not
just about politics and I think Maggie's
very good at playing those roles of you
know sort of very sensitive just just
just very human thank you very good at
that
you